how do you put yourself in the mindset
of somebody that
or majority of the scientific community
or majority of people believe that the
earth
everything rotates around earth how do
you put yourself
in that mindset and then take a leap
to uh propose a model
that the sun is in fact at the center of
the
the solar system sure i mean so that
puts us back in the shoes of copernicus
right 500 years ago where
he had this philosophical preference
for the sun being the dominant body
in what we now call the solar system the
observational
evidence in terms of the measured
positions of planets
was not better explained by the
heliocentric
sun-centered system it's just that you
know copernicus saw that the sun
is the source of all our light and heat
oh wow
and he has you know how he he knew from
other studies that it's it's far away so
the fact that it appears
as big as the moon means it's actually
way way bigger because even at that time
it was
known that the sun is much farther away
than the moon
so um you know he just felt wow it's big
it's bright
what if it's the central thing but the
observed positions of planets at the
time
in the early to mid 16th century
under the heliocentric system was not a
better match at least not a
significantly better match
than ptolemy's system which was quite
accurate and lasted 1500 years yeah
yeah that's so fascinating to think that
the philosophical predispositions that
you bring to the table
are essential so like you have to have a
young person come along
that has a weird infatuation with the
sun yeah
that like almost philosophically is like
however their upbringing
is they're more ready for whatever the
more
the simpler answer is right oh that's uh
it's kind of sad
it's a sad from an individual descendant
of a perspective because
then that means like me like you as a
scientist
you're stuck with whatever the heck
philosophies you brought to the table
you might be almost
completely unable to think outside this
particular box you've built
right this is why i'm saying that you
know as an objective scientist one needs
to have an
open mind to crazy sounding
new ideas and you know even copernicus
was
very much a man of his time and
dedicated his work to the pope
he still used circular orbits the sun
was a little bit off-center it turns out
and a slightly off-center circle looks
like a slightly eccentric
elliptical orbit so then when kepler in
fact
showed that the orbits are actually in
general ellipses
not circles the reason that
you know he needed to cobra his
really great data to show that
distinction
was that a slightly off-center circle is
not much different from
a slightly eccentric ellipse and so
there wasn't much difference
between kepler's view and uh
copernicus's view and and kepler needed
the better data
to go to cobras data and so
that's again a great example of of
science
and observations and experiments working
together with hypotheses and they they
kind of
bounce off each other they play off of
each other and you
continually need more observations and
it wasn't until
galileo's work around 1610
that actual evidence for the
heliocentric hypothesis emerged
it came in the form of venus the planet
venus going through
all of the possible phases from new
to crescent to quarter to gibbous to
full
to waning gibbous third quarter waning
crescent and then new again
it turns out in the ptolemaic system
with venus between
earth and the sun but always roughly in
the direction of the sun
you could only get the new and crescent
phases
of venus but the observations showed
a full set of phases and moreover when
venus was gibbous or full
that meant it was on the far side of the
sun that meant it was farther from earth
than when it's
crescent so it should appear smaller and
indeed it did
so that was a that was you know the nail
in the coffin in a sense
and then you know galileo's other great
observation was
that jupiter has moons going around it
the four galilean satellites
and even though jupiter moves through
space so too do the moons go with it
so first of all earth is not the only
thing that has other things going around
it
and secondly earth could be moving
as jupiter does and you know
things would move with it we wouldn't
fly off the surface and our moon
wouldn't be left behind and all this
kind of stuff so
that was a big breakthrough as well but
it wasn't as definitive
in my opinion as the phases of venus
perhaps i'm revealing my ignorance but i
didn't realize how much data they were
working with
yeah so there's uh so it wasn't
einstein or freud
thinking in theories it was a lot of
data
and you're playing with it and seeing
how to make sense of it so is it
it isn't just coming up with completely
abstract thought experiments yeah
it's looking at the data sure and he's
looking at newton's great work right the
principia
it was based in part on galileo's
observations
of balls rolling down inclined planes
supposedly falling off the leaning tower
of pisa but that's probably apocryphal
in any case you know um the the
inquisition actually did or the roman
catholic church
uh did did history a favor not that i'm
condoning them but they placed galileo
under house arrest
and that gave galileo time to publish to
assemble and publish
the results of his experiments that he
had done decades earlier
it's not clear he would have had time to
do that you know had he not been under
house arrest and so newton of course
very much used
galileo's observations
you